hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey who watched Hobbes and
Shaw if you don't know the plot it's
like Mission Impossible to a better
version yeah for years we've been asking
for man that movie had so much potential
but we deserved a better execution this
is the one I don't remember fate of the
Furious that whoa big ended up getting
along like working together pretty well
by the end of it so in this movie when
Hobbes and shot team-up I'm like what I
thought you guys like pulled off a cool
mission you can clink some Coronas on
the rooftop that was what sparked the
whole justice for Han controversy yeah
maybe it's explaining the movie if you
saw any of our trailer reactions you
know that I especially have been greatly
looking forward to this movie
it delivers exactly what I wanted it to
be I had a really really great time the
least falsely advertised movie oh yeah
it is just as crazy as you want it to be
the banter buddy-cop dynamic between
Dwayne Johnson and Jason Statham it's
like some of the funniest moments we
just kept insulting each other and the
way David Leitch chose to capture a lot
of the taunting moments where it's just
it's like perfectly like they're
centered so well done yeah so freakin
hilarious
I think Dwayne Johnson is actually
hilarious in this movie they're both
pretty funny I think a symptom is only
funny when he's with Dwayne Johnson but
I think Dwayne Johnson overall is pretty
funny in this movie yeah I really like
their performances a lot in this film
and I think their chemistry is really
great and if they did if they made out
their own franchise I'm sure they will
be Hobbes and Shaw I think they could be
up there as like a great action duo yeah
yeah just have such chemistry together
and also the situation comedy plays into
it and they can both fight so you get
free and realistic looking stunts and
stuff like they are a pretty great
action duo and that's good because as a
film that this is just like a generic
villain plot with yeah mission
impossible to throw it on it but it's oh
yeah this movie is so sci-fi now
thing that kind of is kind of annoying
about the charlize theron line and fate
of the furious this is so this is so
much more ridiculous than yourself a
villain I think the tone established
really does a great job on making this
all really work
oh yeah like my only real complaint
about the movie would have to be what we
would check in with Idris Elba's
character because this movie has a
pretty simple beat sheet of how it all
goes for most of the film it's Dwayne
Johnson and just say they bicker then
there's a fight scene and then they
bicker and then we check in with Idris
Elba and then we bicker and there's a
fight scene they bicker and then we
check it with it or so but that's like
that's most of the movie and the thing
is with Idris elbow while he does a
really good job the character in it of
itself is just not altogether that
interesting and that's when the movie
tries to get more serious with what it's
doing and similar to fate of the Furious
where it kind of get bogged down like I
think they the fear is did it so much
that it really like hamper down a lot of
the energy this movie doesn't really do
it that much so this is like it's more
of a nitpick because I don't walk away
thinking about any of this I think this
movie did better by its Vil and only in
the sense that it made it so that his
purpose made him kind of a character and
it didn't make it seem like a big thing
the movie was trying to push you know
it's like he has this whole thing about
the future and the evolution of man and
we're doing this for a right just cause
they don't like lean too heavily into
that is to be like serious well his
scenes are great when he's interacting
with either both or either one of you
know Jason Statham or doing job
everything one of the major highlights
for me someone who I honestly thought
might have been wasted talent she is
incredible in this film like she is just
she's up there with dwayne johnson
vanessa kirby vanessa kirby has
wonderful chemistry with both of the
like different types of dynamics because
she plays this sister shaw but the
chemistry in relationship that she
hasn't both of these characters is
really well done
I think her action scenes are a great
whenever she was on screen I was I was
really to like fully entertaining I
thought she was wonderful
the film isin Azaz as you saw in the
trailer shows it to be hot ya know and
that's kind of what she does now no one
saw her working from dusk till dawn they
said she can't act right she's just hot
so let's uh let's give her like a cool
outfit and some guns but let's not
actually show her kicking ass with a
that Authority baby driver she's hot
Elita battle angel she's hot robot chick
here she's hot Michelle Rodriguez was
you know outspoken about the way the
female characters are treated in the
Fast & Furious franchise and I think
Vanessa Kirby is better than all of them
ya know the treatment of her character
you know I don't think she as naturally
tough as someone like Michelle Rodriguez
who just looks like she can stare at me
and like kick my ass but Vanessa Kirby
her character is just so much more rich
and entertaining to watch in any other
female character need this entire nine
movie franchise yeah I mean it is I
think the same people who've been
writing these for a while so I hope they
take some Pearce more and feel like they
could maybe take some of what they've
done it's like they're clearly capable
of doing it so maybe they can inject
some of that into the future fast movies
one letdown factor to me is the action
is exactly how its pitched in the
trailer and there's a lot more of it
this movie's a two and a half hours long
get a little mind-numbing some of the
time there's a halfway point in the film
I've heard enough people tell me before
watching this like hurt like tell me
personally and hearing it in reviews
normally from movies I don't watch the
reviews before i watch the film I'm like
this house and I are people like Chris
Stockman say this it's Stedman eyes and
it's true there's there's a point in the
movie where it really looks like it's
going to end and then you get like
another 30 more minutes about remember
the trailer and like oh yeah wait a
minute before we even entered any of
that sequence before we ever entered the
moment where I'm sure most people
thought was gonna end I looked at John
like this must be the scene coming up
for we think it's gonna end like I just
knew it was gonna be like this scene and
I think you'll know that you know I
think it's important to actually factor
that in when you're watching this
because it'll make it easier to sit
through the rest of the movie it's like
a for Act movie
yeah well it's in like because of that
if I didn't know that I probably
would have been a lot more impatient
during the last half-hour of this film
but because I was prepped for that and I
saw it coming I was like okay this is
much easier to watch because the last
half-hour it kind of beautiful oh I felt
like I was so prepped for it that like
the last half hour it feels a little
tacked on I mean you probably know what
the hell we're talking about honestly
you've seen the trailer yeah it really
feels like yeah we're putting this in
the movie okay it's not only shot like a
Michael Bay movie yeah it does it does
this dive into his character it's not
structured well yeah do it it's not it
but it's still super entertaining
yes it's still awesome one of the
disappointing elements to the way this
is captured and I kind of get this way
with when James Wan was brought on board
when Gary yeah when F gary Gray was
brought on board you only see little
moments that feel like that director
signature touch it's spares it's kind of
like some of the MCU movies where you're
like did this guy actually direct this
yeah you can see like his his veneer has
been added yeah and I thought David
leeches presence I felt the most in the
humorous yeah it's like the John wick
assumes that you'd want are not here
except for like a couple of lighting
moments the fight scenes in themselves I
was kind of let down by especially the
hand-to-hand ones yeah because of the
fact of you know like this guy's an
atomic blonde he's dead John wick and
then I watched these Hannah Hannah fight
something like oh man they're shot
exactly like every other fast and
furious movie that yeah they're so hyper
edited they're so fast the fun action
moments for me here were the crazy big
[ __ ] like that that's most of the fight
scenes there was some cool hand-to-hand
stuff sure absolutely but for the most
part they were just captured like any
other fast and furious flick and that
was kind of the the letdown factor to me
of knowing who's directing this but that
being said even though the Hanahan stuff
is very much similar to the other ones I
still think the overall tone of this
just a vibe that this one gives off I'd
actually be more excited to see a sequel
to this then I would be too
- nine honestly I would be yeah it's
just more outwardly fun I don't know
there's something about The Fast and
Furious movies that even when they get
super fun there's always kind of they're
trying to be a little more serious about
it exactly because those first four kind
of were so self serious they still have
these scenes that they weave in through
five through eight that are just like
wire I don't need anything I mean they
still do that in this movie there's
still like family stuff and dramatic
moments but I didn't feel like they were
trying to be like no no but yeah there's
a couple of moments this is more like
Deadpool - David Leitch and it is John
wick David oh yeah yeah and if you want
if you were excited by david leitch
coming in to bring his sensibility that
would be a letdown if you love fast and
furious action then you'll yeah I'm
pretty surprised if if you don't enjoy
this movie if you like the other Fast &
Furious films because it's enough to
make it different and the than the
original franchise that is you know
stems from but it's totally similar in
vain to make it a Fast and Furious
presents film yeah if they're gonna do a
universe expansion this is a pretty
decent way to start yes the most
self-aware one of them all - oh it's the
most soulful this movie is feeling
itself at times maybe a little too much
oh yeah they're there they're the
references to their a few Jason Statham
and the rocks other movies their
references to just pop culture yeah he
breaks the fourth wall a bit like it is
like it all over the place movie yeah
terms of how fast and loose its being it
is a double-edged sword because
sometimes the movie does either get kind
of mind-numbing in the sense that like
action can stretch out kind of wide yeah
or it can just be like cut this down you
know with the banter or some of the
dragging dramatic moments or something
overall like if there's one moment
that's dragging pretty soon it'll be
having a blast it yeah it is so fun it
is a super super entertaining film if
you saw the trailers and you wanted to
see it go watch
you're gonna have at least at 80% good
yeah it's not like The Lion King we were
like oh that's exactly what I expected
nothing more yeah there's there's some
fun surprises there are surprises in
here oh yeah well did you see Hobbs and
Shah leave a comment down below let us
know you thought where would you rank it
amongst the Fast & Furious franchise is
the Paranormal Activity the marked ones
of The Fast and Furious people say yes
that's a good metaphor cuz that's a good
sequel totally keeping the vibe you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell I wanted to give a
page in the day shout-out to a man named
Gregory Bullock you see here's how life
works we have topper war tears or you
get a video request of the month to go
up on YouTube Gregory is pledged for
that Gregory is great we are Gregory he
never got back to me about what he
wanted his video to be we know you we
know your personality you would be
perfect to be part of the Hobbes and
Shaw franchise Hobbes Shaw and Bowie
look how cool would that be
you could either be like the combination
of like Sandra Bullock's personality
meets Bullock's personality from
American Dad and then Gregory bollocks
personality you would get a female black
empowered Republican character if you
combine all of those personalities
that's you oh oh
it's called improv maybe that's how you
doing I want to see this character come
to life now and you're gonna add a
singing element in there too you know
and that's like the one thing he'll do
the other there one of those tracks that
plays on the credit yeah yeah yeah he
can collab with a Drew's elbow to be
perfect
no one has filmed the Hobbes and Shaw
video
[Laughter]
[Music]